hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dimension - I'm
still playing from the last go that
looks like where the guy dug into the
tunnel but you didn't do a very good job
boarding that up mister man I'm pretty
sure that anyone would have been able to
creep through that it's especially the
little one the heat from my hands seemed
the heat from my ass what are you
talking about I don't know what he's
talking about here what do you wanna do
okay you know what
ah okay never mind I don't know what the
hell that was talking about is there
some way to like holster my everything
in that way I could like oh you know
what I don't know oh there we go let's
crawl in tunnels oh my favorite tunnels
oh good I like that music okay what are
you kidding me this dick bag was like
two inches from escape he dug a tunnel
and he couldn't get through this way I
bet I can't hammer through this but well
I could if I really wanted to but
alright let's go in this cave of
nightmares he played it up so much gonna
be what is it Oh oh god damn it you
startled me it's just you you know a
monster is all that scary when it's like
I hear him and I'm like go oh it's just
you
come back to play again no oh man I
gotta say this sound they're designing
this game is really good I don't know if
it's just cuz I usually play these
horror game with the volume turned way
up them like really is surprisingly good
like a lot of these things in the game
of just surprisingly good
[Music]
okay oh hey don't you be doing that to
me Pinsky Pinsky hi Becky I'm assuming
that headshots don't matter in this oh
come on oh okay you only took two shots
I got you right in your heart you black
and corrupted heart okay so anyway I
wished I was about to tear which they
throw another monster at me but not that
one
oh you skittering bastard your creepy
ass skittering bastard please sometimes
even the dumb noise startled me in Ewing
forward kind of reminded now of penumbra
because in penumbra they're the first
one um man so long play those Gimple I'm
being very reminiscent about certain
things but yeah there's a lot of going
through tunnels that's kind of reminded
me of that like I'm getting a lot of
elements Oh most god it's spreading like
a cancer hurry
William aren't I William okay and what
could have possibly been in my head like
if okay real talk
if I ever become corrupted with some
evil demonic presence oh you're real I
thought you were gonna take me into
another dimension
what oh that's lovely
no no no I am expecting something
similar a sinister from that but when to
go which legend it is said that her
daughter's murder was the catalyst after
devouring the flesh of another person
she was transformed into a Wendigo which
she is very powerful but constantly
starving roaming the plains lusting for
human flesh it's moments like that I
wished I was a voice actor but I like
what I do now it's a very odd
like steer see I enjoy making videos for
you guys just having fun even though I'm
talking to myself in my own apartment
all alone in my neighbors think I'm
crazy
don't matter to me William my love you
are finally returned for me dear my dear
villian I have missed you so desperately
to us south to the dogs it is my
favorite place I will see you there
please hurry
love Elizabeth xox Oh south to the docks
is that a little bit of innuendo there
lady is that a little bit of no going
down there you think it's gonna be
little oh wow oh no oh no no no oh oh
always with these things store these
things like the Paris nights that were
in my brain huh love the music game
hello mr. skull man what are you doing
yeah okay so new area big place just to
explore all that fun jazz hello shotgun
yes please I'll take a shotgun now where
is it
Chuck I got to say that the map and the
actual things in the environment are
just a little bit off
oh no wait was it talking about all kids
no it's still just a little bit off
goddamn it shut off very you sound very
disturbing it bothers me
hello I love how you're looking at me is
it time to get to me fish a beast
oh come on hang on I got a guy back up
hey how about you died I'd be really
cool I'm gonna run out of ammo if I keep
using my gun where am I now
oh never mind I got plenty of ammo can I
get up there no a few a few that's all I
got to say about that
okay add that I'm continuing forward you
know I I said uh I said my time at band
camp uh before like it got me thinking
about old old things that I've gone
through like I used to be an
exceptionally nerdy kid like
over-the-top nerdy like you wouldn't
even believe it if you saw me like you
you probably believe it because I'm
still pretty nerdy now but I mean just
like the things I oh oh no no how do I
get out okay the things I used to do
like I used to dress in like slacks and
a polo every day in like the sixth grade
okay I need a piece of whatever that is
and so like I would get made fun of all
the time I was like I was like brutally
picked on like I'm not saying I didn't
deserve it no one deserves to be picked
on but man I was like grade a nerd
materials though and not that there's
anything wrong with that I'm not trying
to dissuade you anyone that does that
I'm happy with who I am and who I was
I'm just saying like looking back on it
for me it was really funny to see like
and sometimes I go like oh god why did I
do that like I don't regret any decision
I've ever made my entire life just
because it made me who I am today
like I would never go back and change
anything because I like the person that
I am and everyone should be relatively
comfortable with who they are for the
moving forward and I hope you guys are
like sincerely I hope you're comfortable
with who you are especially when it
comes to things like you
because I used to be so quiet and
reserved but you know around my friends
I was always silly and rambunctious I
mean Wade and Bob can attest if you want
first-person perspective like in private
I've always been like that oh okay well
that's still locked how does that help
me I've always been kind of the very
rambunctious very very silly especially
if you ask my like high school friends
like they always know that I am just
absolutely bonkers sometimes no I'm not
always though I know when to be serious
okay so I'm a little confused I think I
gotta go back like I hate backtracking
in these things but I don't know what
the code could be wait what's this
documents no xox what is that a thing
oh I'm gonna be stuck aren't I I'm gonna
be good
great I made you a bit of creative
cutting if I get stuck the too long I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna be oh like that
oh wait a minute
[Music]
Hey look out dumb I am everybody look at
our dumb markiplier is boy big idiot
there's like back when you were a little
kid I got other stories from band camp
but they're all right then I'm guessing
that's my wife
oh I didn't kill but look good god there
see that sound is like very disturbing
oh come on why does some take do some
take for yep either way just stay down
oh okay wait a minute what the hell
that's a photograph how is it getting
all blue yeah Mia is it oh hello
nope nope no nope nope nope nope nope no
you little buggers and go nowhere okay
lots of shotgun ammo but knows you're on
yeah no shotgun yeah Wow
[Music]
what is it oh hi No thank you you know
you get a sledge damn good because I
don't want to deal with it oh come on a
biscuit yeah look very threatening well
I mean you look very threatening but you
aren't very threatening
anyway more stories from band camp Lee
it was two weirdest things some of the
things that people would say to me like
remember this is 13 you're off shotgun
oh it's got like three barrels though
that's a flashlight but anyway who's
this thing yeah the weirdest thing that
people were say to me like when there's
13 and I don't mean to like offend oh
bloody hands everyone offend people but
I don't even know I'm just saying like
uh-oh I'm trying to remember the exact
scenario there's one kid that I was
talking to he seemed like a cool guy and
he was a to Blair we were walking to
rehearsal and we were just walking with
her instruments and like out of the blue
out of nowhere he started telling me
this a story or like he just started
saying like these were these exact words
out of his mouth I believe man you know
I really like virgins man because you
could rip them apart and I'm like but
why we were talking about music just
like two seconds ago what happened he's
like yeah man don't you and I go like
about say it was like and then like it
was just everyone was trying to brag to
each other I think it was just one guy
that was telling him about this girl
that like fit up popcaan in her mouth
and it's like totally things that should
like not be a thing at that age it's
just like shouldn't be a thing it's like
what the hell is going on in this camp
it was just very very strange place I
don't know if any of you have been to
blue legs farah naaz camp like i said
before but man it was just a weird place
anyway that's enough story time with MA
huh that's enough story time with
markiplier time to get serious
can I get in this boat yep hey why is
there oh hello you little bugger oh
thank you
all right back to normal oh not you you
get to test out my new shotgun husky
thank you have a nice day the zoo a way
to blow both barrels at the same time
hello is anyone here hello man don't
like that
oh okay Oh puzzles you know and got
better puzzles thing going on there
I gotta line them all up perfectly okay
so that one moves that one wall okay
which one does this move oh that one
moves mice well that was easy
I just did a bit order okay never mind
then
oh wait this is that thing oh I got the
thing for the thing and now the other
place good good good good I can go back
cool all right what's a sting house
things tell me else I don't remember
what it was my brain woof oh okay I
thought I heard something my headphones
are like really loud right now so every
sound like anyway okay anyway back oh
well I I can't remember I was saying
something it wasn't a story or anything
it was just something in general but I
felt like it was important I can't
remember it oh oh well it'll come back
to me if it doesn't if not then oh well
I've failed all of you and please berate
me in the comments just go to town on
how awful a person I am please wait can
I go down there I can would there be any
benefit to doing that think so all right
now anyway what party what no no you did
some north um oh god not you back the
best oh come on don't jump it won't kill
me a business yeah oh come on no don't
jump your bets good
BAM [ __ ] Gatorade me [ __ ]
what's with the pile of garbage right in
the middle of there save ha silent
protagonist all he does is he's like the
opposite of link if link was ever like
in a situation where did we doing that
you know did you know the same voice
actor does the same one for both the
down good god go away man you are very
disturbing I do not like you Oh
with the ghosty coos I really don't like
them the normal monsters are fine but
those guys ah
oh not you uh weird weird weird weird
can't blame you huh okay you're dead ah
tell me in let me in let me pardon wanna
you want to run that one by me again the
music can't decide what it wants to do
[Music]
laughing okay laughs and me good thing
there I isn't very good I may be able to
mail it no I find you getting you don't
he's making noise
God you are freaky creatures I just
noticed I haven't gone to psych a
bonkers world in a while why don't I
take a trip down I would be lovely can I
get a save point can i markiplier get a
save point up in this [ __ ] oh hello oh
that's a nice drawing I wish I could
drive a weight that's look familiar
do I know that from somewhere I don't
know maybe maybe not either way alright
what else do you throw at me [ __ ]
oh good trail of blood getting from here
to there see where it goes you know
people have a good job of boarding
things up right before they get murdered
to death seems to be the reason why this
town ain't do so good and also why is
this town do so here because it wasn't
this like thumb prison was oh god no
you're not did you just spit poison at
me you bastard hell no and no absolutely
Frick frack and not know what did I what
is that
no no stop laughing at me
serving bastard laughing give me give me
[Music]
what is that okay okay okay all right I
think I gotta take a pause cuz that they
gonna be there
oh that's just you okay I was like I
doesn't recognize the clanking I was
like what the hell was that
it's really weird oh look he's smiling
like he's no he's not smiling nevermind
that guy's not smiling
oh maybe he is oh god it's just you oh I
could never recognize from this sounds
like I know the burro but just the
clanking I didn't know what that was so
anyway I gotta take a pause here but
either way really I'm really enjoying
this game like I'm having a lot of fun
playing this game I really am I hope you
guys are enjoying watching it because
obviously I haven't seen the feedback
yet I've just been playing it straight
so anyway thank you all so much for
watching for games days for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh